AHMET ALP BALKAN:
Hello, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, OK.
Yeah, so today
we're going to talk
about Cloud Run for Anthos.
I think you've been hearing
about Cloud Run and Cloud Run
for Anthos throughout the day.
And we came here, talked
about building platforms
and high-level abstractions.
Then [INAUDIBLE] came
here, talked to you
about Anthos Service Mesh.
So we're going to try to
put these pieces together,
and let's see if we can build
something higher platform.
So my name is Ahmet Alp Balkan.
I'm a developer advocate.
I'm joined by Jay here from
our San Francisco office.
He's a customer engineer.
And we'll be talking about Cloud
Run and Cloud Run Anthos today.
So as you've seen earlier today,
when you get into the Anthos
world, there are all these
abstractions and components
that you'd like to build a
full-fledged infrastructure
that you can freely
deploy applications.
But when you think of
higher-level abstractions--
for example, your
developers, I bet,
they don't want to
learn Kubernetes.
Most of the developers
ideally should not
be learning Kubernetes.
That's why we want
to build platforms,
we want to build all these
higher-level abstractions.
So it seems like a piece of the
puzzle is missing out there.
And this is precisely what
Cloud Run on Anthos is.
But again, pretty
much any developer
abstraction we built--
for example, in this case,
Cloud Run on Anthos--
it's not the end game.
It takes you to some
level, but maybe there
is something else that
you can put on top of it.
And we're going to
talk about that, too.
So this by no means
is the end game
in terms of the
[INAUDIBLE] experience.
So let's talk about serverless.
I know you didn't come here to
hear about serverless, did you?
So you might think, hey,
I have on-prem stuff.
Maybe I want to do
multi-cloud stuff.
Why are you telling
me about serverless?
And the reason for that
is serverless world
has been taking the
internet by the storm,
because they have done something
that is pretty remarkable.
I can write my application
code, and I can directly
deploy it without
knowing anything
about the infrastructure
whatsoever.
So this might be totally
irrelevant to you.
If you heard about Google
Cloud Functions, Lambda,
and these sort of things, these
sort of technologies, maybe
this is very different than
what you've been already doing.
But there's something
that we can learn from.
And the fact that
your developers do not
care about the
infrastructure anymore,
and they can be productive,
they can write code and go
to production in a very
short amount of time,
I think that's
pretty remarkable.
So when we think
about serverless,
we're seeing that there's
an operational model that
makes serverless serverless,
and there's a programming model.
So first of all, there
is no infra management.
In the serverless world,
they have this place,
they don't touch
machines anymore,
they don't configure load
balancers, firewalls.
And just because the
infrastructure under them
updates regularly and
it's patched regularly,
they just write their
code, and everything else,
their dependencies,
the OS packages,
and the runtimes,
everything, it gets
patched by the cloud provider.
So there's a world
like that out there.
And they pay-per-use.
For example, you
got one request,
you pay for one request.
That's it.
And similarly, they've been
constructing their applications
as little microservices or
little functions, lambdas.
And these applications
are invoked
through events or requests
that come to that application.
So they've been
writing these services.
And I'm assuming
some of you also have
services that sound like that.
So at the end, I think we can
learn something from this.
So serverless, at
the end of the day,
is nothing more than
efficient developers
and efficient operators.
This is what it's
bringing developers
to these sort of platforms.
If you look at it,
like, Google App Engine
was released a decade ago.
That's not new.
We've been doing serverless
for a pretty long time.
And the reason people
have been opting in
for that model is they're
pretty efficient at it.
They can write their code, go
to the production or staging
in a minute or so.
And this is precisely
why I think there is
something to learn from that.
So developers care
about velocity.
They want to write their code.
They want to take their code
and put it into production,
and they want to do
it in a reliable way.
When they ship their
code, they don't
want to hear from their
operators or DevOps
person or the [INAUDIBLE]
that they broke everything.
So they want that
reproducibility.
They want that monitoring.
They want these pieces that
makes the whole thing reliable.
So this is where we
introduce Cloud Run.
So Cloud Run, as
of last week, it's
a generally available product.
It's Google's
serverless platform
that lets you run any container
image in Google's fully
managed infrastructure.
You give us a container
image, let's say
there's a web server
in that image,
and that's the end of the story.
We run that image for you.
We give you an endpoint
that is fully secured.
We scale it for you.
You call Google,
you say, I'm going
to have a Black
Friday sales coming up
tomorrow, or in a week or so.
Can you schedule me?
Can you allocate something
like this to me, that is,
like, maybe I want
5,000 containers?
And then Google tells you,
OK, you're good to go.
And then next thing you
know, Black Friday, 9:00 AM,
you're getting hundreds
of thousands of requests,
and Cloud Run can effectively
scale that for you.
And we're going to talk
about how that looks like.
So as I talked
earlier, Cloud Run,
you come with a container
image that you're already
familiar with.
That's the price of entry.
As long as you can package your
application into a container,
you can deploy to Cloud Run.
And you can run any
language and framework.
So this is how it differs
than most other serverless
platforms, because normally,
when we think of functions
and app engine paradigms, we're
restricted to certain languages
and their versions.
Normally, you can run Python
2.7 and 3.2 or something,
but you can't go beyond that.
So Cloud Run gives
you that flexibility.
And it's fully managed
infrastructure.
And you pay for what you use.
And you get rapid
autoscaling that effectively
handles traffic spikes.
So you're still
probably thinking
this is irrelevant to me.
This is not quite what I do.
But anyway, I'm
going to show you how
Cloud Run looks like in action.
Can we switch to the
demo machine, please?
So this is Google Cloud Console.
You're probably familiar
with that already today.
So this is the Cloud Run UI.
When I say create a service, the
only thing that I'm asked about
is, what is your
container image?
So I'm going to
type an image here.
I'm going to talk about this
image in a bit actually.
So let's actually go
to the repository.
So I have a repository here,
publicly available on GitHub.
I'm randomly going to deploy
some software from GitHub.
This service claims to be
converting Word documents
to PDF.
OK, let's see how it does that.
I see a Dockerfile here.
Cool.
I guess I'm going to build
a container with that.
So if I go to that Python
image, Python source code,
I'm going to see that down
here, this program is actually
nothing more than something
that pulls into LibreOffice.
If you're not familiar,
that's the OpenOffice.
So this is sort of what
we call legacy software.
There is, like,
15-year-old program
that I can run in a container
so I can accept requests.
I get a Word file, and then
I give it to OpenOffice,
I get a PDF output,
and I send it back
as a response to the request.
So this is what the
application looks like.
I already built that Dockerfile.
So I'm going to
directly deploy it.
I come back to the Cloud Run.
It asks me, where do
you want to deploy?
I want to say, let's deploy on
Cloud Run, fully managed first.
And then I say, allow
every single request
without authenticating
people, because I want
to build a public application.
OK.
So what's happening
right now is Google Cloud
is taking my application image
from Google Container Registry,
and it's going to deploy it
on my fully managed platform,
and it's going to
give me a URL back.
So that URL is going to be
fully secured with HTTP.
I can do IM and access
controls and stuff like that
if I want to.
So in a few seconds here,
hopefully the service
is going to come
up, and we're going
to see that the application
is running completely managed.
So at that point, I can
give that URL to anyone.
I can run a TV ad with that,
because I'm not managing
any infrastructure anymore.
I'm not in the business of
managing anything regarding
the operations of
this application.
So here I get this application.
I click to it.
Here it's built for cold start,
because it's the first time
I deploy the application.
So it's coming up.
But essentially, it's
running this application,
which is a PDF converter.
I think I'm running into
internet issues here.
Anyway, we're going to come
back to that later maybe.
Yeah, that doesn't seem
to be loading right now.
I think this is internet
conference Wi-Fi failing us.
OK, let's go back
to the slides now.
We're going to come
back to that later.
All right, can we go back
to the slides, please?
Slides, please.
AUDIENCE: Slide latency.
AHMET ALP BALKAN: Slide latency.
You know what?
Until the slides
come up, I'm going
to click on this once more.
Nah, it's OK.
I think the Wi-Fi's failing
me pretty well right now.
Let's go back to
the slides, please.
(LAUGHS) All right.
Yeah.
So essentially, what I just did
there is I deploy the legacy
application, because I was
able to put it in a container,
and then I was able
to give it to Google,
so that it can run it in a
fully managed environment
that is with rapid
autoscaling and scale to zero.
And then at the end, I got
this HTTPS endpoint that
was fully managed by Google.
So what if you want
these functionality
in your Kubernetes cluster?
So this was precisely
where Cloud Run on Anthos
comes into picture.
So we want to give
you the choice
of where you want to have
this developer experience.
Because as a developer, I can
just build a container image,
and go to a pretty well
managed environment that
already simplifies a lot
of the operations for me.
So this is where Cloud for
Anthos comes into the picture.
It's the same
experience that you
get on a serverless platform.
It runs in your GKE Kubernetes
cluster next to your Kubernetes
workloads.
So this is still Kubernetes.
You're still running
a Kubernetes cluster,
but you give your developers
a higher-level abstraction.
And if you want to customize
all the autoscaling
and how the load balancing work,
this is pretty customizable,
and I'm going to
touch on that shortly.
So your developers might be--
maybe they want a UI.
So this is what I did.
I used the UI.
I could have used
the CLI as well.
If you're into infrastructure
as code-- for example,
in the previous talk, you've
seen Vic and his friends demo
an application that is purely
deployed from a YAML file.
So if I want that, I
can still go that route.
I can write a YAML file,
and I can deploy that.
And under the covers,
the way Cloud Run
and Cloud Run on Anthos
work the same way
is because they both use this
thing called Knative API.
And Knative is that
open technology
that makes this possible
to run your applications
either on Google's fully managed
platform or in your clusters,
either on cloud or on-prem or
maybe another cloud provider.
So Knative is that open
source API and implementation
that codifies these practices
of running microservices
or serverless applications
on Kubernetes.
It's an open API.
It is jointly developed
by Google, Red Hat, IBM,
and few others.
So by adding Knative,
which is, in this case,
managed by Cloud Run on
Anthos to my cluster,
I'm able to run stateless
applications more effectively.
I can go somewhere,
I can click a button,
and then that application
is pretty much managed
and autoscaled for
me at that point.
I don't have to worry about
configuring Horizontal Pod
Autoscalers, memory-based
scaling, and these sort
of things anymore.
So in terms of autoscaling,
if you look at Kubernetes
today, you're probably
writing all these,
like, Horizontal Pod
Autoscaler configurations
that are memory- and CPU-based.
So actually, something needs
to happen, like, for example,
your CPU utilization
needs to hit 70%, 80%,
and then at that
point, you're going
to get autoscaling happen.
But by then, it
might be too late.
So in Knative case, we're
doing rapid request-based
autoscaling.
Anytime a request
comes, that's an input
to the autoscaling machine.
So if I get suddenly
100 requests,
and I can't handle 100
requests, that actually
means that I need to
hold onto those requests
and add more pods, so that
I can send the traffic to.
And the other thing
is scale to zero.
Maybe you don't care about this.
But actually, if your
application is not running,
this gives you a greater
ability to fit more applications
into one cluster.
If an application does not get
any requests, it's not running.
Next time it gets the request,
we wake up the application.
But at the same time, we
hold onto that request.
We don't drop the request.
So this is not
available in Kubernetes.
And this is what you
get with Knative.
And similarly,
normally in Kubernetes,
you have the connection-based,
like, TCP-based load balancing.
I'm sure if you're using
this in production,
you probably realize
that's not the best way
to do load balancing.
And in Knative case, we do
per-request load balancing
and traffic splitting.
So this lets you do [INAUDIBLE]
rollouts or blue/green
deployments.
And this is all possible
because in an Anthos cluster,
there is Anthos Service
Mesh providing load
balancing capabilities and
Stackdriver support that lets
you monitor your applications.
So now we're going to go back
to the demo machine again.
And let's try to
Cloud Run on Anthos,
and how different
could it actually be.
So I think I'm going
to turn off my Wi-Fi.
I'm hoping I'm connected
over the wire right now.
Let's try this.
It was a previous
application that I
was trying to connect to.
I don't know why it's
still not working.
But let's go ahead and
deploy the same application
in a Cloud Run on an
Anthos cluster this time.
So I go here, and I type
the image name again.
Yep.
And then this time, I'm going
to say, let's choose a Cloud
Run on Anthos cluster.
And in my project,
it turns out there
is a GKE cluster available.
I choose that.
And then I say, let anyone
connect to this application.
Then I go ahead and
create the application.
So again, the same thing.
I use the same
developer experience.
As a developer,
this is what I see.
I have an application.
I have maybe, like,
a memory CPU setting.
But at the end of the day,
I just want to deploy it.
And in a few seconds,
I get a URL back.
I click on it.
So this was the application
that you were supposed
to see in the first place.
As you can see here, I'm able
to deploy the same application
to Cloud Run on Anthos.
But I told you earlier,
this is still Kubernetes.
So let's go out and
take a look at that.
So here, I'm going to
bring up my Cloud Shell.
If you don't know that, that's
a pretty cool feature we have.
So let's take a look at
my Kubernetes cluster.
Let's try to understand
what's going on here.
And as you can see, I have a
three-node GKE cluster here.
And what I just deployed was
actually a Kubernetes object.
So for example, if I
close this down here,
if I look at the
YAML, well, this
looks a lot like
Kubernetes, right?
This is all these
specs and containers,
resources, memory limits.
So now let's try to
actually make sense of this.
So here, I'm going to ask
for an API type called--
usually, I'll get Kservice.
So Kservice is the Knative
service abstraction.
It's not greatly named,
because there's already
a Kubernetes Service object.
But hold on for a moment.
So it seems like I already have
the PDF application I deployed
in the cluster running.
So I see the service here.
If I do the kubectl,
I'll get svc,
which is the normal
Kubernetes service.
I can see that there's already
a service created for that PDF
application here.
And essentially, it's
making the application
that I just deployed
available within my cluster.
So if someone else wants
to call this application
within the same cluster,
they can do that.
Maybe I can limit connectivity
to only the cluster.
I can say, don't allow
anyone externally
calling this application.
I can have a completely private
microservice deploy this way.
So for example,
let's take a look
at the pods, what's
running in this cluster.
So you're going to see that
there is a pod running,
but it's actually going away.
It's terminating.
And the reason
it's terminating is
because I didn't send it
any requests for the past 30
seconds or so.
So if I go back and refresh,
so right now, a new container
is coming up.
It came up, and it
served the application.
So if I go back and run
kubectl, I'll get pods again.
As you can see here,
there's a new pod running.
And those just started,
like, eight seconds ago.
So this is sort of
how Knative works.
Let's go back to
the slides, please.
Can we go back to
the slides, please?
All right.
So this is Cloud Run on
Anthos in a nutshell.
So what I just did was I had
the same developer experience.
I went from the UI,
which just told me, hey,
choose your container image.
I specify my
container image, just
like I'm doing
serverless stuff, but I
was able to get this in
my Kubernetes cluster.
So we saw how Knative
works under the covers.
It's still Kubernetes objects.
Your DevOps people and
your administrators
and operations people can go
and configure these objects
further.
You can impose Kubernetes
policies on them.
You can use Anthos
Config Management
to spread these objects or
apply policies that would
limit access to these objects.
Because this is
still Kubernetes.
And I want to actually go
back to the demo machine
momentarily, because I forgot
to show the traffic splitting.
So let's actually see that, too.
I just deployed another
application here.
It is called hello-app.
So this is running a
similar application image.
If I click on that, that's
going to come up shortly.
As you can see, this
is a Hello World 1.0.
As a developer, I can say,
hey, deploy a new revision.
For example, I get 2.0.
And then I say, let's go
ahead and deploy this.
And after I deploy
this application,
I can actually say,
let's manage the traffic.
For example, I want to send
50% of the traffic to v2.
So I go ahead and Save this.
Again, this is possible because
we're using Anthos Service
Mesh under the covers.
We get that load
balancer with Istio.
We get the same load
balancing capabilities
that you would normally
get in an Anthos cluster.
So I go back to the application.
Now every time I refresh, I'm
either going to get v1 or v2.
So refreshing, 1, 1, 1, 2.
So that's pretty much how
traffic splitting works.
If I were to set this to
a value like 5% or 10%,
I would be able to do
[INAUDIBLE] rollout
or blue/green deployments.
So this is pretty much
how traffic splitting
works in a nutshell.
Let's go back to
the slides, please.
Yeah.
And finally, this
is still Kubernetes.
We're not adding new complexity.
This is a software-based stack.
I did load balancing
with software.
I configured a new
application with software.
I didn't involve any
sort of hardware in this.
I was able to use what's already
in your cluster, which is
the Anthos Service Mesh setup.
If I want to get metrics
out of this application,
this is still possible.
So now let's briefly talk about
migrating your applications
to Cloud Run.
So what sort of applications
actually fit into Cloud Run?
So first of all,
your application
needs to be stateless.
A lot of services are,
it turns out, stateless.
Yes, there are stateful
services as well.
But if you have microservices,
front ends, anything
that handles events
or processing queues,
these sort of applications,
actually, they're
fault tolerant.
You can kill them, or
you can scale them up,
and they usually
pick up the load,
and they continue where
they left off, or something
like that, that helps
you build applications
that are resilient.
So if you have an
application, you
can make it work on
an HTTP or gRPC port,
you can run it on Cloud Run.
And ideally, if it's
not an application that
takes 10 minutes to start--
as you see here, every
time I get any request,
I start a new instance of
that, and that instance
stays around, so that I can
send more requests to it.
But additionally, you
can configure the Knative
autoscaler.
I can go and say,
hey, you know what?
I don't want cold starts.
So that's the biggest
problem in serverless.
People say, there's cold starts.
I don't want cold starts.
In that case, you
can say, please
scale my application
to maybe minimum one
instead of going to zero.
You can say, I don't want zero.
I want to keep it one.
So you can have
that on Cloud Run.
So here, I have the usual
Kubernetes Deployment
and Service file.
They say, hey, I have
this application.
Here's the image.
Here's the CPU requirements.
And then to make this
application accessible
internally to my cluster,
I define a service.
So let's go through
this and see if there
are commonalities
that we can read out.
For example, replicas, 1.
I don't need
replicas, 1, because
with Cloud Run on
Anthos, I'm getting
autoscaling out of the box.
I don't need to worry about
how many replicas are running.
And there are all these labels.
I don't know if anyone here
actually goes and configures
labels on their
deployments, so they
can choose them and have them
overlapping labels and stuff
like that.
So that doesn't
happen very often.
And similarly, on
the Service side,
there are all these labels.
And I'm trying to do
the selector, because I
need to go back
to the Deployment
and match to the policies
deployed by the Deployment.
And you know, I'm still in the
business of doing port numbers.
This is pretty interesting.
With Cloud Run on
Anthos, you don't have
to do port numbers anymore.
The port number is given to you.
And you can customize that.
So there is that.
So why don't we get rid
of the Service object
altogether and take the good
parts of the Deployment?
So that gives us the new
Knative Service object.
As you can see here,
it's pretty brief.
It only has a few lines.
I can just specify
my deployment spec,
which contains the only critical
information about my container.
What is my image?
What are my resources?
If you need to add labels,
you can still go and do that,
but you don't have to.
So compared to the
Deployment object,
I think we've come a long way.
As you can see, pretty much
what I just changed was
I changed the API group,
and I took the parts that
mattered into the new object.
And now I'm actually running
on Knative, just Cloud Run
on Anthos.
So here I'm going
to transfer to Jay.
And he's going to talk
to you about eventing,
which is a critical part
in serverless developer
experience.
[APPLAUSE]
JAY SMITH: Thank you.
I want to create a
data-driven organization.
Has anybody heard that before,
maybe in the field, maybe
their manager said that
at some point in time?
Who heard something about
data-driven organizations?
All right.
Does that actually
mean anything?
It sounds like one
of those buzz terms.
Oh, we're data-driven.
We collect a lot of data.
We like data.
But what are we
doing with the data?
Are we just storing it in some
warehouse in the Nevada desert?
Is it actually being
used for something?
My theory is that
when people say
they want a data-driven
organization, what
they actually mean is they want
an event-driven organization.
They don't want to just
get arbitrary data coming
into their application.
They actually want to know
that something is happening out
there in the world that
their application needs
to respond to.
Maybe you have a rideshare
app, and somebody has just
ordered a ride, or
maybe there's traffic,
and you want to be able
to update the estimated
time of arrival.
This data needs to
serve a purpose.
So when we start
framing data as events,
then it starts to
serve a better purpose
for our application,
something we can actually
build a solution towards.
And in fact, if you
saw one of the earlier
slides when we were
talking about serverless,
one of the six, I
guess you could say,
segments of serverless
was event-driven.
And how do we do that?
Well, Knative actually has
a component called Eventing.
So Cloud Run is based
on Knative Serving.
Knative Eventing is
another component
that makes up this whole
Knative suite, if you will.
Eventing is--
well, it allows you
to declaratively bind
between event producers
and deployed services.
So now you're able
to just create
a producer or a source that
creates the events, that
collects the events,
and then just
deploy services that
reads said source.
You can scale from a few events.
Maybe you do a update
on your inventory
at the end of the day, or maybe
you want to do a livestream.
And then you can create custom
event pipelines to connect
with your own existing systems.
So perhaps you have some
kind of Kafka cluster
out there, something we're
going to talk about very soon.
So Knative Eventing
allows you to do all this.
This is actually
pretty important,
because you might
be saying, well,
what happens in that earlier
setup when we deployed?
It gave us a URL.
Why don't I just kind
of turn on the fire hose
and send all of my
data to that endpoint?
That'll work, right?
Maybe.
You can actually
do a lot of things
with Knative Eventing. here
you have a source, which
could be your container.
It could be GitHub, maybe
something changed in GitHub.
It could be your Kafka cluster.
It could be something
in Kubernetes itself,
and it can just go and deploy
to your service, which is fine.
But what happens when
you want to fan out?
What happens and you want
certain services to receive
certain events?
What if you want
to define events?
Can't really do that as
easily when you're just
doing the straight HTTP.
And then, of course,
how do you guarantee
the events are sent if
you're doing it that way?
So what Knative will allow you
to do is do a more complex--
or Knative Eventing,
rather, will
allow you to do a more
complex serving of your events
rather than just a
turning on the fire hose,
so to speak, onto
a HTTPS endpoint.
An easier way to
look at it, and what
I'm going to be showing you,
is we have this Kafka cluster
out here.
We have a Knative source.
Knative source, that
is essentially--
think of it as kind of
a bucket, if you will,
where all the events
go to, and that
serves as the source of all
truth for the events that
come in.
Then the broker's kind of
another abstraction layer
that you can then push
the event to the app.
So the source just collects
that information, broker kind of
gives it a little
more intelligent,
and then the app or service is
what actually functions there.
And it uses the
event to do whatever.
Simple idea in terms of the real
world is we have our user here.
They have a mobile phone.
They want to order a
pizza with their app.
We use Confluent Cloud.
And Confluent is
actually founded
by the creators of Kafka.
And they actually have
a fully managed solution
that you can host on GCP, too.
So you get open source Kafka,
all the benefits of open source
Kafka, plus an SLA in support.
So if you're an
enterprise, wouldn't it
be nice to have somebody
else worry about your Kafka
versus your developers?
And then, of course, while
we're talking about that,
you have the Knative.
So let's go ahead
and look at our demo.
I actually recorded
it, because I
wish I had the confidence
to do a live demo.
Well, you know, internet
Wi-Fi is what it is.
But hey.
Or hotel Wi-Fi.
Before we start
playing the video,
just going to explain a little
bit about what you will see.
I created a-- oop, there
it is, but it's small.
Anyway, so what you will see is
I created a small little app.
All it does is it
pings Alpha Vantage.
Alpha Vantage is a API tool
that essentially will give you
different financial data,
so stock markets, currency
exchange, all of that.
You get, like, 500
free calls a day.
So hey, it's perfect
if you're doing a demo.
It will check, and then
it will send the results
to a Kafka cluster, and
then we will show you
my Knative Eventing.
Can we restart that real quick?
Wish I could stop
myself from clicking.
So I'm in the Kafka cluster.
I'm in my Kubernetes
cluster, rather.
This all has Knative Eventing
and Cloud Run installed.
Here's my service.
Look, there's Cloud Run.
There's currency-app.
That's the application
I deployed on Cloud Run.
Now we are looking--
oop, there's the API.
There's what the URL is.
That's my cluster I
showed you earlier.
So I'm going to go
ahead and take that URL,
and go to Postman, and start
sending some API calls.
Now, this is my endpoint.
Basically, it takes
two currencies, USD
and Japanese yen.
Now, because of hotel Wi-Fi
when I was recording it,
this took a little while.
But what it's going
to be doing is
it's going to be comparing and
giving you the exchange rate.
It'll show you what the
exchange rate is there.
There you go.
So remember that number.
Now we're going to go,
and this is actually
consuming my Kafka cluster.
So Kafka got that number.
Now, what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to go ahead and get
all the pods that
are running in that
namespace that I created.
Event display is kind of
a bucket, if you will,
that displays all the logs that
have been sent to the broker.
We're going to go ahead and
look at the logs, so kubectl.
We're going to go ahead
and look at those logs
and see what we can find.
Now, this is using a format
called CloudEvents, which
is an open source
CNCF-built, I guess,
format for setting events.
So we're keeping
everything open source.
It stores the data in Base64.
So let's go ahead and decode it.
And hey, look at that.
It matches.
So in pretty much
real time, I was
able to send that event
to my Kubernetes cluster.
So let's go ahead
and wrap this up.
Why Cloud Run on Anthos?
Well, easier deployment and
operations for microservices.
I read a study--
I can't remember where--
but it said around 25%,
30% of your developers'
time is actually
used doing non-developer work.
So we hear the term "full
stack developer" a lot.
So that usually means I'm
going to have to write YAML,
I'm going to have
to manage nodes,
to set up databases.
We make it easier for
you to use microservices
by abstracting away a
lot of that operator work
for the developers
to deploy, and then
also make it easier
for the operators
to work on the stuff
they need to work on,
and not necessarily need to be
a part of the deployment process
when an application version
needs to be deployed.
Because of that,
you have increased
productivity and velocity.
Hey, those developers get
that 25%, 30% of their time
back to actually
develop applications.
And of course, the
end of the story
is that it enables your
developers and operators
to be more successful and focus
on the things that matter.
And thank you.
And here's how you get Cloud
Run, and all of our code
is in these repos,
and get some tips.
And yeah, thank
you for the time.
[APPLAUSE]